but what have you and Joe had to really
double down on in the short term to make
sure you've got cash flow and all those
things going as well the really good
sales strategies come through so really
good email sequencing definitely heavy
on the cold calling still like I'm a
True Believer that like those old school
sales taxi because they still work like
anyone that says cold call instead so
don't believe them in the slightest we
are still able to have very good wins in
terms of just getting directly through
to Founders cro CMOS and picking up
roles that way but they're more likely
to have a lot more competition so is it
more worth my time to carry on searching
for a better quality role that I'm more
more likely to feel